how would your mom feel about your
relationship with your brother now
I think she would be
I think she would be sad Prince Harry
opens up about how his late mother
Princess Diana would feel about the
Fallout between him and his brother
Prince William it is going to be some
time down the line and that is largely
down to the fact that William simply
cannot forgive Harry not just for
leaving but for how he left the Duke of
Sussex is asked about the rift in a
preview from his upcoming interview with
Good Morning America's Michael Strahan
he reveals how Diana who tragically died
in a car accident in 1997 when he was 12
and William was 15 would feel about
their strained relationship if she was
alive today I think she would be sad
I think she'd be looking at looking at
it long term to know that there are
certain things that we need to go
through to be able to heal the
relationship
um I have felt the presence of my mum
more so in the last
two years than I have in the last 30.
she would be really infuriated about
would be the fact that they've had this
split and because she always said to me
and not just one spot on several
occasions
Harry is Williams backup in the nicest
possible way he's his ring man he's the
one who helps William in this difficult
job that he will have in the future
because it's a lonely job and she always
felt that Harry should be there as his
as his backup and I think everybody
wants them to come back together again
because because he's
together they're so much stronger
Harry's full GMA interview airs Monday
ahead of the release of his highly
anticipated Memoir spare hitting shelves
on January 10th and I think the greatest
threat and the greatest concern
certainly for the Royals is the
forthcoming autobiography yeah and sneak
peeks have been hitting the internet
including a report from the guardian
which obtained an excerpt in it Harry
claims William physically attacked him
after the two got into an argument over
Harry's wife Meghan Markle Harry
describes an alleged confrontation at
his London home in 2019 and claims his
brother called Megan difficult rude and
abrasive and that conversation allegedly
turned into a shouting match Harry
writes quote he set down the water
called me another name then came at me
it all happened so fast so very fast he
grabbed me by the collar ripping my
necklace and he knocked me to the floor
I think there was just just a great
sense of mistrust within the family they
just simply feel that any reconciliation
is not on the cards because they can't
they can't trust that it's not going to
end up in a TV show or in a book tempers
are high and there's a lot of tension
there's a lot of upset there's a lot of
anger and there's still a lot of
resentment and I think any reproachment
is is really quite far down the line
William will be taking this very
personally I think he's incredibly upset
and feels very badly betrayed by his
brother
foreign